my name is Amy Pagani and I'm an editor
on the obituaries desk at the New York
Times or as some friends call me the
angel of death
in fact people will ask me isn't it
depressing working on our bitchu aires
and thinking about death all the time
but you know when I tell them obits
aren't about death they're about life
they're interesting they're relatable
often about something you never knew
recently for example we had the obit for
the inventor of the sock puppet everyone
knows what it's not puppet is but have
you ever thought about who created it or
what their life was like open source
signature form of journalism an art form
if you will it's an opportunity for a
writer to weave the tale of a person's
life into a beautiful narrative since
1851 the New York Times has published
thousands of obituaries for heads of
state famous celebrities even the person
who came up with the name of the slinky
there's just one problem only a small
percentage of them chronicled the lives
of women and people of color
that's the impetus behind the project I
created called overlooked which tells
the stories of marginalized groups of
people who never got a knowbut it's a
chance for the newspaper to revisit its
168 year existence and fill in the gaps
for people who were for whatever reason
left out it's a chance to right the
wrongs of the past and to refocus
society's lens on who is considered
important I came up with the idea when I
first joined obituaries in 2017 the
black lives matter movement was at a
rolling boil and the conversation on
gender inequality had just started
bubbling up again and at the same time I
wondered as a journalist and as a woman
of color what could I do to help advance
this conversation people were coming out
of the shadows his house
or even justices that they had faced and
I could feel their pain so I noticed we
would get these emails sometimes from
readers saying hey why don't you have
more women and people of color in your
obituaries and I thought yeah why don't
we since I was new to the team I asked
my colleagues and they said well the
people who are dying today are from a
generation when women and people of
color weren't invited to the table to
make a difference perhaps in a
generation or two we'll start to see
more women and people of color in our
obituaries that answer just wasn't
satisfying at all I wanted to know where
all the dead women so I started thinking
about how we hear about people who have
died right number one way is through
reader submissions and so I thought well
what if we were to look at international
newspapers or scour social media it was
around this time when it was everything
was swirling in my mind and I came
across a website about Mary Outerbridge
she was credited with introducing tennis
to America in 1874 and I thought well
one of the biggest sports in America was
introduced by a woman does anyone even
know that and did she get in New York
Times obituary spoiler alert she did not
something I wondered who else we missed
and it sent me on this deep dive through
the archives there were some surprises
the pioneering journalist I to be Wells
who started the campaign against
lynching the brilliant poet Sylvia Plath
Ada Lovelace
mathematician now recognizes the first
computer programmer so I'm back to my
team and I said what if we were to tell
their stories now it took a while to get
by in there was this concern that you
know the newspaper might look bad
because it didn't get it right the first
time the results it was also a little
weird to sort of look back at the past
rather than cover news stories of our
day but I said guys I really think this
is worthwhile and once my team saw the
value in it they were all in and so with
the help of a dozen writers and editors
launched on March 8 2018 with the
stories of 15 remarkable women and while
I knew that the work my team was doing
was powerful I didn't expect the
response to be equally powerful I had
hundreds of emails there from people who
said thank you for finally giving these
women a voice there were there were from
readers who said I cried on my way to
work reading these stories because I
felt seen for the first time and they
were from colleagues of mine who said I
never thought a woman of color would be
allowed to achieve something like this
at the New York Times I also got about
four thousand readers submissions
suggesting who else we might have
overlooked and some of those are my
favorite stories in the project my
all-time favorite is grandma Gatewood
she survived 30 years of domestic
violence at the hands of her husband one
day he beat her so badly beyond
recognition he even broke a broomstick
over her head
and she threw flour in his face in
response when the police arrived they
arrested her not him the mayor saw her
in jail and took her into his own home
until she could get back on her feet
then one day she read this article in
National Geographic about how no woman
had ever hiked the Appalachian Trail in
its entirety alone and she said you know
what I'm gonna do it reporters caught
wind of old grandma who is hiking
through the woods and at the finish they
asked her how did you survive so rough a
place but they had no idea which she had
survived before that so overlooked has
become wildly successful it's becoming a
TV show now on Netflix
I cannot wait to see this thing come to
life something like 25 different
publishers have reached out to me with
interest in turning over looked into a
book
all of this clearly shows how timely and
necessary this project is it's also a
reminder of how newspapers document
what's happening in our world every
single day and we have to make sure not
to leave out key people that's why even
though it's been so meaningful to look
back in the past I'm plagued with a
lingering question what about the future
of obituaries how do I diversify those
that was my original problem right so to
start answering this question I wanted
to gather some information I went down
to the sub sub-basement level of the New
York Times building to the archives we
call it the morgue and I asked for some
guidance from our archivists there he
pointed me to a book called New York
Times obituaries index so we hands it is
in the New York Genealogical Society and
they digitized it for us and then a
programmer wrote up a program that
scanned all those headlines for mr. mrs.
lady sir all the sort of gender defining
terms and what we found was that from
1851 to 2017 only about 15 to 20 percent
of our obits were on women so next I
worked with a programmer to build this
tool called a diversity analysis tool
it's a very dry name but bear with me
it's super helpful it breaks down the
percentage of our obits months a month
women to men okay if that doesn't sound
like much to you
this is how it used to calculate it
before so I asked this programmer to
program in a goal and that goal was 30%
from the year of overlooks launched
March of 2018 to March of 2019 I was
hoping we could get to 30% of our obits
on women it was a number we hadn't
achieved in 168 years and i'm happy to
say we did it we got to 31%
it's awesome but it's not enough next
year hoping to get to 35 percent and
then 40 percent until we achieve parity
and then I'm hoping a partner with this
programmer again to build a similar tool
to measure people of color in our obits
that was something I wanted to do with
overlooked to is to include men of color
and I finally got to do it with a
special section for Black History Month
where we told the stories of about a
dozen black men and women again it was a
really powerful experience many of these
people had been slaves or were a
generation removed from slavery a lot of
them had to make up stories about their
past just to get ahead in life and there
were these patterns of their struggles
that came up again and again Elizabeth
Jennings for instance had to fight for
her right to ride on segregated
streetcars in New York City a hundred
years before Rosa Parks did the exact
same thing with buses it was just a
reminder of how far we've come and how
much more we still have left to do
overlooked as including other
marginalized people as well recently we
had the obit for the computer programmer
Alan Turing believe it or not this
brilliant man never got an obituary even
though his work decoding German messages
during World War two helps end the war
instead he died a criminal for his
sexual orientation and he was forced to
endure chemical castration great things
like this Obus project did not come
easily there were a lot of fits and
starts as I worked hard to convince
people is worth getting it off the
ground there were moments when I faced
great self-doubt I wondered if I was
crazy or I was all alone if I should
just give up when I've seen the reaction
in this project I know I'm not at all
alone there's so many people who feel
the way I do and so yeah not many people
think about obituaries but when you do
you realize they're a testament to a
human life they're the last chance to
talk about somebody's contribution on
the world they're also an example of who
society deemed important a hundred years
from now somebody could be looking into
the past to see what our time was like
I'm
lucky as a journalist to have been able
to have use this form of storytelling to
help shift a narrative I was also able
to get an established institution to
question its own status quo little by
little I'm hoping I can keep doing this
work and continue refocusing society's
lens so that nobody else gets overlooked
thank you
[Applause]